this is like a late 70s
electromechanical towards the end of
electromechanical pinball machines after
this all the control stuff went
electronic so they were instead of
driving the solenoids with switches they
were using transistors that were all
controlled by computer in the head the
play fields remain pretty much the same
because you're moving the ball around so
you need an electromagnet for the
solenoids and the apply power to it and
it moves a ball in this case it's an
electromechanical machine so all the
control is done with switches that are
controlled by relays it's basically
considered a fixed program
electromechanical computer I know that
sounds like a big scary word but
basically it it is it's fixed program
because you cannot program it you can
change some of the features but it's not
really programmable everything's
hardwired there's I don't know if you
can see but there is a ton of wire in it
there's one device here that could be
akin to the quad you'll see it
see I'll rotate right there that's
that's called the score motor that comes
into play when something needs to be
counted all the relays to our supply
route signals to the score units up
there to do the counting all the
switches on the plate built-in
information in this what's called the
mechanical board on the bottom and
according to how it's wired up send so
many pulses off of the score motor it's
got different units like a ball count
unit a bonus count unit depending on the
machine it just has different step up
and step down counters
it's basically what they are and they're
totally electromechanical so what
started out is a really simple game
where you just put the ball in a pocket
you added up your own score eventually
just got more and more complicated until
the point where they pretty much had to
have a computer on it because it just
got so complicated